Beyonce knows what she's doing but it's
a guy you know she's got that tick-tock
do you think she's seen my chick talks
well should I scream and throw up and
cry first of all I got a wish you miss
Britney a happy birthday belated how did
you celebrate I know we're in quarantine
but like it looked like you still had a
special day it was a special day I had
some friends come outside and very
hygienic ly hand me flowers right asks
gloves and then I did his doing call
with my friends from home I made them
prepare a two-minute presentation on
topic of their choice so they arranged
from mangroves and diminishing wetlands
to art history it's so fun I feel like
this was also a little birthday gift
that like Kim Petra's dropped the video
for Malibu which you are in some other
like but good on Kim for there's so many
internet stars bonito Skinner and all
that and next to who Jesse James Demi
Lovato are you kidding my white music
video as Demi Lovato if I think about it
too much I'll start crying
well you God when she asked me to be a
part of it I was gay we love her and
what a summer Bop right honestly yeah
beach music driving to the beach I'll
listen one of my favorite things about
you because I feel like we're kindred
spirits and I think that's also because
you're obsessed with pop culture as much
as I am as much as et is and a lot has
gone down in the last couple weeks I
need to get your take on okay starting
with Beyonce's rapping in the savage
remix
luckily me are you kidding I don't think
about Beyonce if she does this just out
of the blue anyone used to it by now but
we're not never so that's all I have to
say about that is Beyonce knows what
she's doing but it's okay don't you love
how plugged in she is because the lyrics
she's like she's spinning about
tick-tock about oh [ __ ] when I dance I
said I looked at her I said you know
she's got a tick-tock do you think she's
seen my tik toks
well should I scream and throw up and
cry I know she's got a snapchat cuz her
and blue be doing them filters so I know
that they're right there Jax honey no
she's got her finger on the pulse I'd
bet because she's got a tick tock good
how'd she know about savage to begin
with bang wait speaking of though how
amazing is it that yogic cats say so and
savage they're the top two songs on the
Billboard Hot 100 you feel like maybe
chick talk had a major play in that and
influence absolutely yeah the whole top
ten like for the past couple weeks
months have been tic toc songs blinding
light yeah Old Town Road was purely
because of tick tock rocks and all of
those songs like that's crazy see like
that's why Beyonce was sleeping on the
promo she didn't need it she was like
the top here we go this is it name on
edge like that's it
okay another thing that was really buzzy
this past week was Adele's recent
Instagram Holmes boss I no one has ever
looked as good as she did in that
picture with the the Roach killer
pointed heels stood that waist was
snatched the hair yeah I didn't
recognize her at first if I'm being
honest I hope like you know everyone
obviously his gag she lost the weight
but I hope she's like happy you know I
know a lot of because I follow a lot of
bloggers like that who they lose all the
way and they're like I still hate myself
like I'm really still unhappy with my
body cuz that doesn't just go away so I
hope that she like threw the weight loss
journey like really it's feeling herself
like what do you think the next era of
Adele's gonna look like music wise
because of all I think it's gonna be
like a thank you next
to equate it to ariane of love self love
forgiveness moving on it's not I mean we
all obviously love a sad album that's
why we like when the weekend breaks up
with someone I'm really shy but I don't
know with Adele I don't know I'm excited
this will be definitely different from
anything she's ever done before are we
gonna get some pop hits we might get
another tik tok dance challenge courtesy
of all I love it
last but not least Zayn is expecting a
baby his first child with gigi hadid I
know you love 1d yeah what did you make
of that and also are you still hoping
that Zayn will be a part of this rumored
One Direction reunion that's supposed to
happen this summer I think he will be
you think on all that stuff that leaked
about what it's coming out in October
whatever he's on the like song credits
so if he doesn't show up he's cancelled
but regardless that baby is gonna be
probably the most beautiful thing that's
ever graced the planet of gorgeous are
you kidding
what gorgeous flavor I'm just hoping
that they will see what the baby name is
though we just got that weird Elon Musk
Rimes moment so like is that was that a
sound or a name like I don't know like
the noise that computers make when they
malfunction that's
[Music]